And the Internet has been
teeming with fresh allegations
of ties
between the Russian government
and Ziploc bag full of pee,
Donald Trump.
Rumors are swirling about
everything from Russian servers
communicating with the Trump
Organization to allegations
that the Kremlin
is blackmailing him with
a secretly-recorded sex tape
of him in a Russian orgy.
-(audience groaning)
-Yuck! Well, to be fair...
To be fair, he didn't know
it would be an orgy.
He was just having sex
with one Russian woman,
and then, there ended up being
four other women inside of her,
-so it's not really...
-(laughter)
-(cheers and applause)
-Easy mistake.
Totally easy mistake.
But... but
as deliciously scandalous
as these rumors sound,
as of right now,
the FBI has found
no clear connection
between Trump and Russia.
The rumors have no hard proof,
and it kind of feels like
a last-ditch effort
to throw anything imaginable
at him to see what sticks.
Now, don't get me wrong.
He's still
a glowering hemorrhoid.
But all of this is distracting
from the stuff he actually does
and also the upcoming election.
So, comedians,
since we're not verifying
our sources here
and throwing out wild things
that have no basis in anything,
what have you heard about Donald
Trump's connections to Russia?
-Janet. -Um, I heard
they have these totally crazy
slumber parties where Putin,
like, braids his comb-over,
and then they, like, eat ice
cream right out of the carton!
-(screaming)
-HARDWICK: Oh, my God,
they're the best of friends.
Points. Points.
Dana Gould.
He loves Russia so much
that once at The Comedy Store,
he offered
to Yack-off Smirnoff.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-(laughter)
Very well played.
-VARNEY: Poor man.
-Nate.
Putin gave him a tour
of his submarine,
-and Trump said it's "huge."
-HARDWICK: Yeah. Points.